naftalí bennett es multimillonario y ex
emprendedor tecnológico hijo de padres
nacidos en eeuu
el ex comando de las fuerzas especiales
vendió su startup por 145 millones de
dólares en 2005 y se aventuró en la
política y luego en el partido likud se
convirtió en jefe de gabinete y un
aliado cercano de benjamín netanyahu
jugó un papel importante en la política
israelí incluso después de dejar el
likud sirvió como ministro de defensa de
2019 a 2020 pero benet ha tenido una
relación complicada con su antiguo
mentor debido a diferencias personales
no ha ocultado su deseo de convertirse
en la nueva figura principal de la
derecha israelí mientras impulsa una
economía ultra liberal benet quiere que
el país adopte una línea dura contra
irán además estaba a favor de la anexión
de dos tercios de la cisjordania ocupada
en el pasado el ultraderechista ha
dejado muy clara su oposición a un
estado palestino
creo que soy el único nuestro partido es
el único partido en este podio que se
opone a la fundación
estado palestino dentro de la tierra de
israel entre jordania y el mediterráneo
en oposición y con la pandemia de
coronavirus en 2020 bennett amortiguó su
retórica de derecha para centrarse en la
crisis de salud moviéndose para ampliar
su atractivo mediante la publicación de
planes para contener el virus y ayudar a
la economía en noviembre de 2020 dijo a
medios de israel que el país necesitaba
dejar de lado cuestiones como la anexión
y centrarse en obtener el control de la
pandemia sanar la economía y reparar las
divisiones internas
[Aplausos]